you are watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video it
seems that things are once again moving
faster than anticipated with alternative
energy technology wind and solar power
are great but the main issue of these
forms of power generation with storing
energy for later use until now Tesla
energy and Elon Musk can be making
headlines in recent weeks do you pulling
off feats that many analysts thought
would be years away in this video we'll
take a look at what's been going on in
early March Tesla energy turned on the
switch for a huge solar farm and energy
storage facility that will help how the
Hawaiian island of Kauai in Hawaii the
electric carmaker Tesla is powering up
its plans for energy storage in fact
it's industrial battery packs and now
helping a utility in Hawaii generate
enough electricity for an entire island
we're able to show that we can directly
absorb solar power throughout the day
into these batteries and then discharge
it back at night and stabilize it even
though we might have clouds coming over
or even though it might not line up
directly with when people want to use
the energy this can solve that problem
for those of you into the effects the
kawaii Island is where the lilo and
stitch movies took place and is also
featured in over 70 Hollywood films
anyway Tesla's farm is the first
utility-scale solar energy system in the
United States that can meet electricity
demand even at night it's one of the
biggest battery systems on the planet
the project has 55,000 solar panels and
272 Tesla Power Packs
these can provide 62 megawatt hours of
storage and will provide 13 megawatts of
power for the grid so why Hawaii
apart from being a sunny location Hawaii
has no pipelines running to it so to get
power currently barrels with fuel have
to be shipped in this makes oil
expensive for the island the idea is
that with solar and battery storage
don't have to ship in less oil
meaning that
they save money the company in charge of
the islands energy utilities will
purchase power from Tesla's farm at a
set cost of thirteen point nine cents
per kilowatt hour this is less than the
current cost of oil for away Tesla
energy isn't just starting working laser
in Southern California 396 Tesla
batteries have been installed to suck up
excess electricity from the grid during
the day and feed it back into the grid
as needed especially at night
batteries to charge our phones
flashlights and run all kinds of
electronic gadgets right how about
powering up your home these large white
boxes don't look like much but Southern
California Edison says they could change
the way homeowners get their energy in
the future it's technology that wasn't
there before and we're now ready to
deploy it where it's needed locations
where it works the Tesla battery system
which can power fifteen hundred times
more than four hours was actually part
of an emergency response the emergency
arose because it was projected that
California would have energy shortages
due to a leak at a natural gas storage
facility in California aging nuclear
plants have been closed or phased out
putting even more pressure on utilities
to find other ways to feed the grid
utility executives say that energy
storage is the natural solution the
California battery plant came online in
late January so this event may not seem
like much to many people out there but
this feat serves as a powerful precedent
it shows that utilities can actually use
battery systems to replace conventional
power plants this recent progress has
even taken seasoned professionals by
complete surprise Michael Jay pick up
president of the California Public
Utilities Commission in response to the
Tesla system states quote I had
relatively limited expectations for the
battery industry before 2020
I thought that it would not really
accelerate
and begin to penetrate the electric grid
or transportation world for a while to
come once again technology is clearly
moving faster than we can regulate and
quote the whole battery system was
manufactured by Tesla shipped installed
and ready for operation in three months
all the batteries cooling safety systems
and other equipment are packed inside
the casings ready to load onto delivery
trucks it's almost a plug-and-play
system the lithium battery packs come
from Tesla's Giga Factory in Nevada the
factory is able to set a hundred Boeing
747 and is one of the biggest buildings
on earth the Giga factory will soon also
make Tesla energy the single biggest
battery manufacturer on earth the large
economy of scale makes all the
difference here it's the reason why this
kind of thing can be done now and hasn't
been done before many would argue that
producing all of these batteries is
damaging to the environment but of
course this issue has already been taken
into consideration the batteries are
recycled by Tesla once they've been
decommissioned right now new batteries
are built from raw materials that come
in via rail straight into the factory
for optimum efficiency and minimal waste
in other words is pretty much a closed
manufacturing system the mother of all
vertical integration structures another
cool thing about the Tesla power pack is
that they're extremely scalable so you
could buy one to power your business or
look up a few hundred to run an island
or even the state Tesla energy will
expand operations into other areas of
California America and even overseas one
such place that's been proposed is South
Australia so why South Australia well in
September 2016 South Australia suffered
a statewide blackout as infrastructure
was damaged during a storm good evening
the cause of a blackout which plunged
more than a hundred thousand South
Australian homes and businesses into
darkness remains a mystery
not suddenly becoming even darker at
10:30 last night 110,000 homes and
businesses were blacked out until the
early hours traffic lights dangerously
deemed from above we were a city divided
in two
all sort of just starts to demonstrate
leaving the shopping center everything's
gone we're not sure exactly sure we know
hot we know what happened because not
sure why 150 megawatts of power was
being supplied from Victoria last night
concerns now just how much of an impact
the loss of Port Augusta a lynx at Power
Station will have when it closes by
March recently there was another
blackout due to a heat wave because
there wasn't enough power to meet demand
Elon Musk proposed oh he could fix South
Australia's power issues by installing
an 80 megawatt hour power pack like he
did in Southern California the deal is
as follows the energy problem will be
solved with a Tesla battery system
within a hundred days if this doesn't
happen South Australia gets the system
for free
musk himself has a big vision for
stationary energy storage
he states that quote is something I
think will probably be as big as the car
business long-term it will actually have
a growth rate probably several times
that of what the car business is per
year the growth in stationary storage is
really underappreciated
it's a super exponential growth rate and
quote okay so this all sounds well and
good but before we get too carried away
there are still some important questions
that need to be answered for example how
much exactly do these systems cost no
direct figures have been given that
being said whatever the cost is it
should reduce over time
as production ramps up secondly what is
the ultimate life of the battery packs
in real-world scenarios again we're not
sure in conclusion environmentally
sustainable battery systems like Tesla's
power packs are a great solution to
solve the intermittent nature of solar
and wind energy although maybe still a
little early to tell this concept does
seem promising
storing excess power and delivering it
when
neither will become an integral part of
the world shift to renewable energy
anyway I hope that you enjoyed this
video on some of the cutting-edge stuff
that's going on the Tesla energy from
around the world in a general way things
really seem to be moving it's pretty
cool to live in a time with great shift
in the status quo it can be so clearly
witnessed thanks for watching guys don't
forget to subscribe to this channel if
you just stumbled across it this has
been to gogo you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next video
cheers guys have a good one cold fusion
are you thinking
[Music]
[Music]